Dyna-Q is an algorithm
developed by Rich Sutton
intended to speed up learning or
model convergence for Q learning.
Remember that Q learning is model free.
Meaning that it does not rely on T or R.
T being, our transition matrix and
R being our reward function,
it doesn't know it.
Q learning does not know T or R.
Dyna ends up becoming a blend of
model free and model based methods.
Here's how it works.
So let's first consider
plain old Q learning.
Dyna is really in
addition to Q learning.
So let's start with
the regular Q learning and
then look at how we add Dyna into it.
So we initialize our Q table and
then we begin iterating.
We observe s, we execute action a and
then we have observe our new
state s prime and our reward R
within updater our Q table with
this experience tubal and repeat.
And we do that over and over and over
again, interacting with the world and
our Q table becomes better and better.
So when we augment Q
learning with Dyna-Q.
We had three new components,
the first is that we
add some logic that enables
us to learn models of T and
R then for lack of a better term
we halucinate an experience.
So rather than interacting with
the real world like we do appear with
the Q learning part and
this is expensive by the way.
We hallucinate these experiences,
update our queue table and
repeat this many times,
maybe hundreds of times.
This operation is very cheap compared
to interacting with the real world.
So we can leverage
the experience we gain here
from an interaction with the real world,
but then update our model
more completely before we step out and
interact with the real world again.
After we've iterated enough times
down here maybe 100 maybe 200 times.
Then we return back up here and resume
our interaction with the real world.
The key thing here is that for
each experience with the real world,
we have maybe 100 or
200 updates of our model here.
Let's look at each of these components
in a little more detail now.
So in this part where
we update our model.
What we really want to do is
find new values for T and R.
The point where we update our
model includes the following.
We want to update T, so I'm calling
it T prime for the moment, which
represents our transition matrix and
we want to update our reward function.
Now, remember that T is
the probability that if we
are in state s and
we take action a will end up in s prime.
And r is our expected reward if we
are in state s and we take action a.
I'm going to show you in
a moment how we'll update T and
R Here's how we
hallucinate an experience.
First, we randomly select an s,
second, we randomly select an a,
so our state and
action are chosen totally at random.
Then we infer our new state s prime,
by looking at T.
And we infer a reward, our immediate
reward R by looking at big R or R table.
So, now we've got s, a, s prime and r.
Or a complete experience tuple and
we can update our Q table using that.
So, the Q table update
is our final step and
this is really all there
is to die in a queue.
We've added these three sections and
what's missing and I'll get to in just
a moment is how do we update our
model of t and our model of r?